tengo una transformación lineal de que
va de rn en rn y comienza una
transformación lineal la puedo
representar mediante una matriz
de modo que te dé x sea lo mismo que la
matriz a por el vector x y en el vídeo
pasado vimos que era interesante
encontrar los vectores que no cambian de
dirección con la transformación t es
decir que si tomo la transformación t
del vector b que es lo mismo que
multiplicar ave por la matriz a entonces
simplemente el resultado es de la forma
lambda por b es decir no cambian de
dirección quizás cambien solo de escala
y veíamos que estos vectores son
interesantes porque me permiten
encontrar bases interesantes bases en
las que sea fácil calcular y por eso
llamamos a estos vectores los vectores
propios de la transformación t y a este
factor lambda lo llamamos el valor
propio correspondiente a este vector
muy bien bien y ya tenemos una idea de
por qué estos vectores resultan ser
interesantes pero no tenemos un modo de
encontrarlos digamos actualmente si me
das un vector
yo puedo verificar si es o no un vector
propio pero no tengo un modo sistemático
de encontrarlos así que bueno vamos a
hacer esto bien entonces vamos a buscar
soluciones a la ecuación a x b es igual
a lambda por b lambda por b ahora bien
una solución evidente es la solución 0 b
es igual al vector 0
y definitivamente es una solución pero
normalmente regularmente el vector 0 no
es considerado un vector propio una de
las razones es que el vector 0 no nos
sirve para formar una base otra razón es
porque no está claro cuál sea su valor
propio correspondiente puesto que no
importa qué valor le demos a lambda la
ecuación siempre se satisfacería así que
vamos a restringir nos a las soluciones
que no son cero que no sean el vector
cero y vamos a ver si podemos jugar un
poco con esto y encontrar una forma para
encontrar al menos los valores propios
lo que voy a hacer es restar a x b de
ambos lados de la ecuación
entonces 0 es igual a lambda b - a x b
el vector b rector lo puedo describir
como b por la matriz identidad de gm por
m por el vector b recuerden que b está
en r m
así que puedo sustituir esto en la
ecuación
y déjenme los cambios de lado y escribir
esto como lambda por la matriz identidad
la matriz identidad dni por n por el
vector b menos a por el vector b y esto
debe ser igual al vector 0
ahora bien tengo una matriz por b menos
otra matriz por b como el producto de
matrices por vectores es distributivo
puedo escribir esto este modo lambda por
la matriz identidad menos la matriz a
todo eso por el vector b y eso debe
darme el vector 0 porque esto de aquí es
alguna matriz no sé cuál sea pero es
alguna matriz de hecho esta es la razón
por la cual cambiaba por la identidad
por b para poder escribir esto como un
producto de matrices y poderlo
factorizar factorizar la ve más bien y
escribirlo de este modo
así que tengo este producto de alguna
matriz por b es igual al vector 0
ahora sí estoy suponiendo que ves
distinto de cero si ves distinto cero
qué es lo que sucede pues bien ve ve
pertenece al espacio nulo de esta matriz
al espacio nulo guardando unidad a la
nulidad o el espacio nulo de la matriz
lambda por la matriz identidad menos la
matriz a igual esto se ve algo
complicado y quizás un poco enredado
pero se simplifica si pensamos que el
lambda por la identidad menos a es en
realidad una matriz b así que la
ecuación anterior se convierte en b por
b es igual a 0
depor b es igual a 0 ahora bien
recordemos que el espacio nulo de la
matriz b está definido como los vectores
x que están nrm tales que ve por el
vector x me da 0 en el vector 0 pues
entonces me satisface esta ecuación
estoy suponiendo que satisface esta
ecuación
y todo esto salió de suponer que era un
vector propio de la matriz a así que
tengo un miembro del espacio nulo que no
es el vector cero el vector cero siempre
está en el espacio nulo pero en este
caso de no es el tercero así que el
espacio nulo de la matriz lambda por la
identidad menos aa
su espacio nulo espacio nulo de esto es
no trivial es no trivial esta condición
sólo significa que el vector 0 no es el
único miembro del espacio nulo
y quizás ya lo sepan o quizás lo
recuerden de algunos vídeos anteriores
de álgebra lineal bien pues resulta que
esta condición nos dice muchísimo acerca
de cómo son las columnas de una matriz
de resulta que las columnas de una
matriz de son linealmente independientes
si y sólo si
el espacio nulo de la matriz de la
nulidad de la matriz de es trivial es
decir solo contiene al vector cero y por
el contrario si tenemos una matriz cuyo
espacio nulo no sólo contiene al vector
cero entonces debe tener columnas
linealmente dependientes
bien pues pasemos ahora traduzcamos lo
que acabamos de hacer a la estructura de
la matriz lambda por la identidad menos
a recuerden que todo eso es en realidad
una sola matriz
así que la matriz lambda por la
identidad menos debe tener columna
linealmente dependientes ahora bien esta
condición es completamente equivalente a
que la matriz no sea invertirle y esto
pasa si sólo así el determinante la
matriz es 0 pero como todo esto es
equivalente puedo decir que si el
determinante es 0 entonces la matriz no
es invertible entonces sus columnas son
linealmente dependientes y por lo tanto
existe un elemento no trivial en el
espacio nulo de esa matriz y esto
significa que entonces existe un escalar
lambda y un vector b tales que la
ecuación a por b es igual a lambda b
tiene solución
así que si existe una solución de que no
sea 0 que satisfaga esa ecuación
entonces esta matriz
debe tener determinante 0 y también el
otro sentido es cierto si el
determinante es 0 entonces debe existir
un número escalar lambda y un vector b
distinto es 0 tales que a por b sea
igual a lambda por b bien pues déjenme
escribir todo esto esto realmente es lo
más importante que estamos viendo en
este vídeo así que a por b es igual a
lambda b
para algún vector de distinto del vector
0 para ver distinto de 0 sí y sólo sí
y solo sin
el determinante determinante de la
matriz lambda por la identidad menos
es igual a cero recuerden que el
determinante de una matriz siempre es un
número escalar así que no vayan a
confundirlo con el vector cero y quizás
estén preguntando bueno ya esto de qué
me sirve esto como me ayuda a encontrar
los valores o los vectores propios pues
resulta que el hecho de que el
determinante de lambda por la identidad
menos a tenga que ser igual a cero si yo
sustituyó la matriz a por la matriz que
representa mi transformación t
entonces el determinante me da una
ecuación con incógnita lambda que puedo
resolver y de este modo obtener los
valores propios